[Music]
we wanted to politics
hopefully we don't need
[Music]
hey honey
Anna you're not talking tonight no
talking aiya I spoke to Tommy Tommy
don't know nothing about it
[Music]
you look very smiley makes change
where'd you dig the clothes
I'm saying you got to watch what you say
watch what you say
no me listen you know he's gonna say
this here Voltaire and he said that I
don't agree with what you say in fact he
says I despise what you say but I will
defend to the death your right to say it
you might have died we don't like [__]
right yeah we're not Europe really come
yummy wait we let you speak facebook
facebook well guys picture loser I don't
know what to be fair you guys have you
quiet welcoming when we get
it's very important that's a wonderful
area when communication by the way he is
quite thirsty if you've got waterproof
but today Steve Steve I believe you're
gonna use that's why we invited I didn't
come if this is really you know speech I
don't want to disturb
I would never have
did you try what did you say what
country you got my boy Arabs rules so I
didn't see guys right now
[Music]
he's speaking today
in addition three please
[Music]
okay
No yes yes I would yes I would
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
pinnacle in an illegal place but if you
really want to know I don't know why and
I genuinely defeats the whole purpose I
was invited by Newsom by Kanan
are you here alone
[Music]
because they broke him he should march
towards yourself March
specifically not just my speed in there
[Music]
I've seen your stuff a day so tell
yourself I'm here because he's been
invited to the White House you know we
winnin by it
yeah we've been stopped my entry no
freedom of speech
so you don't have my feet about you stop
my feet no we're not serving if you
don't we have relationally cannot
believe and I cannot believe that
regulations about this this whole event
is about this
this event is respecting every
performance it's gonna be online
[Music]
600 such things
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way
[Applause]
Mykel Skinner on to this know your
intentions just yeah we can verify it
yeah you got you've got a formal
invitation for the whole point of
today's speech was free speech but these
are like ultra right-wing people that
kind of organized a yeah so we thought
that they had done that and the basis
that okay because they're saying that if
you know the one that you disprove the
most that means big we actually check
with or with a chance to do gesture and
that would offer us protection except it
is a bad security and it wouldn't be
this kind of holy first claim and so all
cameras work was quite firm handshake a
few of the people there who have very
like negative intentions yeah so and
there's so many cameras